Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
________________
La psychanalyse
« Freud n'était pas un génie de la science,
mais de la propagande. »
— Hans Eysenck, Déclin et chute de l'empire
freudien
Lors de ma dernière année d’étude en
école de commerce, en 2011, j’ai choisi
en option un cours d’introduction à la
psychanalyse. Je me souviens encore la toute
première séance : les diapositives de la
prof défilaient, et lorsque la diapositive
consacrée à la définition de la psychanalyse
est apparue, j’ai tiqué. Il était écrit
« La psychanalyse est une science… ». Je
n’ai pas pu m’empêcher de lever la main
pour demander à la prof si elle était bien
certaine qu’on pouvait définir la psychanalyse
comme une science. Et… elle l’a mal pris.
C’était pile l’époque de la sortie du
pamphlet de Michel Onfray sur Freud, livre
qui faisait grand bruit et mettait à mal
la crédibilité de la psychanalyse dans l’opinion
publique. La prof a répondu à ma question
comme les psychanalystes ont réagi au livre
de Michel Onfray : la remise en cause de la
psychanalyse est une attaque politique ; c’est
une persécution orchestrée par des mouvements
xénophobes, voire antisémites.
De telles réactions épidermiques sont révélatrices
de la fragilité des idées psychanalytiques,
parce qu’une pensée solide n’a pas besoin
de quitter le terrain de l’argumentation
pour se défendre. Pour autant, il ne faut
pas en conclure que tout est à jeter. Certaines
conceptions de la psychanalyse sont certes
des idées fausses qui ne correspondent pas
à la réalité de l’esprit humain ; mais
d’autres conceptions — dont une bonne
part ont été puisées dans l’histoire
de la pensée — semblent justes et sont
utiles pour comprendre le monde.
De surcroît — et c’est là, à mon avis,
la principale raison du succès de la psychanalyse
— elle est séduisante. En effet, elle est
une théorie déterministe de l’esprit,
une terre inconnue dont elle postule qu’elle
obéit à un enchaînement nécessaire de
causes et d’effets. Et en faisant la part
belle, dans les déterminismes de l’esprit,
au secret et à la sexualité, elle attire
naturellement l’attention de l’opinion
publique. La psychanalyse est de loin la plus
influente des écoles de pensée psychologique
du XXe siècle.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux questions
suivantes :
* Qu’est-ce que la psychanalyse ?
* Que retenir de Freud ?
* Quelles sont les idées essentielles de
Freud ?
* Quels sont les développements majeurs de
la psychanalyse ?
* Quelles sont les limites de la psychanalyse
?
Qu’est-ce que la psychanalyse ?
Je vais tout d’abord élucider le sens du
terme « psychanalyse ». Je définirai ensuite
plus précisément ce qu’on appelle la psychanalyse.
Enfin, je vous expliquerai comment on peut
caractériser le praticien de la psychanalyse,
le psychanalyste.
Que signifie le mot « psychanalyse » ?
Freud, le fondateur de la psychanalyse, emploie
ce nouveau terme pour la première fois en
1896 pour désigner la méthode d'analyse
psychologique de Josef Breuer, un médecin
autrichien qui est son ami proche et avec
lequel il travaille (ils écriront un livre
sur l’hystérie ensemble). La méthode de
Breuer — qui inspirera fortement Freud — consiste
à retrouver des émotions bloquées provoquées
par des événements oubliés, et à faire
parler le patient afin de lever le blocage
émotionnel (Freud et ses collègues considéreront
même jusqu’à la Première Guerre mondiale
que c'est Breuer qui a inventé la psychanalyse).
Sur le plan de la langue, le terme « psychanalyse
» est formé par la jonction de « psycho
» (le mot grec qui signifie « l’esprit
») et du mot français « analyse » (issu
du grec analuein, qui signifie « défaire
une trame »). Le terme « analyse » signifie
dans l’absolu l’étude d’un ensemble
en le décomposant en ses éléments constitutifs
; mais depuis le XVIIIe siècle, il désigne
l'examen psychologique de comportements. Pour
l’anecdote, au début, Freud (qui maîtrise
le français et travaille en partie dans cette
langue) parle de « psychOanalyse » parce
qu'il se trompe sur les règles de formation
des mots français à partir du grec.
Ainsi, dans l’absolu, le terme « psychanalyse
» désignerait l’étude de l’esprit humain
en le décomposant en ses éléments constitutifs.
Il y a bien cela dans la psychanalyse au sens
strict, mais elle est quelque chose de bien
plus précis.
Dans le détail, on peut distinguer 3 usages
du terme « psychanalyse » :
1. l’usage du grand public, qui tend à
appeler « psychanalyse » toute pratique
d’analyse psychologique ou toute psychothérapie
;
2. l’usage intellectuel, qui appelle « psychanalyse
» toute conception selon laquelle il existe
une partie cachée dans l’esprit humain
et il faut mettre à jour cette partie cachée
afin de guérir les troubles psychologiques
;
3. l’usage des partisans de Freud, pour
lesquels le terme « psychanalyse » désigne
exclusivement la théorie et la pratique fondées
sur les textes freudiens.
Comment définir la psychanalyse ?
Le terme « psychanalyse » ne suffit donc
pas à comprendre ce qu’elle est. Pour cela,
il faut connaître sa doctrine et son histoire.
Pour faire simple, la psychanalyse est une
école psychologique qui prétend guérir
des troubles psychiques et/ou physiques en
rendant conscientes des pensées dont l’ignorance
est à l’origine des troubles. C’est donc
simplement une nouvelle version de la vieille
idée du secret pathogène (que j’ai évoquée
dans des leçons précédentes), selon laquelle
l’homme se rend malade en se cachant certaines
choses à lui-même ou en se mentant à lui-même.
Mais la psychanalyse enrichit l’histoire
de la psychologie en construisant autour de
la vieille idée du secret pathogène une
doctrine, ainsi qu’une méthode thérapeutique.
Mais quelle est la définition « officielle
» de la psychanalyse ?
La définition classique pose 3 éléments
constitutifs :
1. la psychanalyse est un procédé d’investigation
de processus psychiques (lesquels demeurent
inaccessibles sans le procédé) ;
2. l’investigation nourrit ensuite une autre
dimension constitutive de la psychanalyse
: elle est aussi une méthode de traitement
des troubles névrotiques (c’est-à-dire
des troubles nerveux sans base organique décelable)
;
3. enfin, la psychanalyse est une série de
conceptions psychologiques acquises grâce
à l’investigation et au traitement, et
les psychanalystes considèrent que ce nouveau
savoir constitue progressivement une nouvelle
discipline scientifique (je reviendrai sur
la question de savoir si la psychanalyse est
bien une science).
« La psychanalyse commença comme une thérapie,
toutefois ce n’est pas comme thérapie que
je voulais la recommander à votre intérêt,
mais en raison de sa teneur en vérité. »
— Freud, Nouvelles conférences (1933)
Après, la domination de Freud n’a pas empêché
la psychanalyse de se diviser en diverses
écoles qui proposent diverses définitions.
Après la Première Guerre mondiale, ses disciples
se plaignaient du fait que le terme « psychanalyse
» soit utilisé à tort et à travers. Certains
reprocheront notamment aux thérapeutes américains
de s’appeler « psychanalystes » alors
que leur pratique n’a plus rien à voir
avec la psychanalyse.
Qu’est-ce qu’un psychanalyste ?
Le psychanalyste est le thérapeute qui suit
la méthode psychanalytique. Freud appelait
ses clients « malades », « patients », ou
« névrosés » ; les psychanalystes contemporains
les appellent désormais « analysés », voire
« analysants » pour suggérer que c’est
le client qui fait lui-même le travail, et
que le psychanalyste n’est qu’un médiateur.
Si « psychiatre » et « psychologue » sont
des titres légaux liés à un diplôme universitaire,
ce n’est pas le cas du titre de « psychanalyste
». Il n’est pas nécessaire de suivre une
formation pour s’en prévaloir — aucun
pays au monde n’a posé une telle condition
(à ma connaissance). Ainsi, n’importe qui
a le droit de faire de l’« analyse psychologique
» et de se présenter comme « analyste » ou
« psychanalyste » — de la même manière
que n’importe qui peut se dire philosophe,
historien, comportementaliste, coach, graphologue
ou astrologue. Rien n’empêche des psychanalystes
« autodidactes » ou « autoproclamés » de
se définir comme des professionnels, alors
qu’ils n’ont suivi aucun cursus « psychologique
» ou « psychiatrique », ni même « psychanalytique
».
C’est pour cette raison que Freud a favorisé
la création de l'Association psychanalytique
internationale (International Psychoanalytical
Association [IPA] en anglais) en 1910.
En 1925, cette association a posé les 2 règles
que doivent suivre les psychanalystes qui
souhaitent qu’elle les reconnaisse :
1. il faut étudier les écrits du fondateur
;
2. il faut faire une « analyse didactique
» (c’est-à-dire se faire psychanalyser
par un confrère) auprès d’un analyste
sorti d’une école agréée par l’association.
Toutefois, Freud lui-même relativisera l’importance
des règles afin de favoriser la diffusion
de sa nouvelle discipline. Le titre de « psychanalyste
» sera encore plus facile à obtenir lorsque
Jacques Lacan créera sa propre société
de psychanalyse, l’École freudienne de
Paris, en 1964 : les deux règles sautent,
n’importe qui peut s’inscrire.
« Le psychanalyste ne s'autorise que de lui-même.
»
— Jacques Lacan
Que retenir de Freud ?
Je vais tout d’abord vous résumer le parcours
de Freud (Sigmund de son prénom). Je vous
expliquerai ensuite comment il a fondé la
psychanalyse ; puis je vous présenterai les
cas les plus connus parmi ceux qui lui ont
permis d’élaborer la doctrine psychanalytique.
Enfin, je vous parlerai de la postérité
de Freud dans les sociétés occidentales.
Qui est Freud ?
Sigmund Freud est un médecin, plus précisément
neurologue, autrichien qui a vécu dans la
seconde moitié du XIXe siècle et dans la
première du XXe.
Il naît en 1856 dans une famille juive de
l’Empire d’Autriche (dont le territoire
était plus vaste que l’Autriche actuelle).
Dès l’enfance, il fait preuve d’intelligence
et d’une grande puissance de travail, c’est
pourquoi il est le préféré de ses parents.
Ils lui répètent qu’il est exceptionnel
et lui réservent un traitement de faveur
: il a sa propre pièce pour étudier. Il
passe un temps fou dans les livres — ses
parents l’autorisent même à manger seul
dans son bureau afin qu’il gagne du temps
de lecture — ce qui explique son exceptionnelle
culture littéraire.
Il a bien sûr d’excellents résultats scolaires.
À l’adolescence, à l’heure de choisir
sa voie professionnelle, il est tenté d’imiter
son meilleur ami de l’époque, qui choisit
le droit pour s’investir en politique — cependant,
l’admiration de Freud pour Darwin le décide
à s’inscrire en médecine. Il lit pas mal
de philosophie pendant ses années à la fac
de médecine (d’où la dimension philosophique
de la psychanalyse) ; il envisage même à
un moment de faire un doctorat, mais ses études
de médecine sont trop prenantes. Il rencontre
Martha Bernays, sa future femme, à 25 ans.
Le mariage, et sa consommation, sont repoussés
pendant 4 ans — ce qui fait souffrir Freud.
En effet, il manque d’argent, et il veut
disposer de son propre cabinet de consultation
avant de fonder un foyer.
Comment fonde-t-il la psychanalyse ?
« Je me sens en droit d’affirmer que personne
ne peut savoir,
mieux que moi, ce qu’est la psychanalyse.
»
— Sigmund Freud, Contribution à l’histoire
du mouvement
Contrairement à ce laissent croire Freud
et ses plus proches soutiens, la psychanalyse
ne sort pas ex nihilo de son seul génie créatif.
Elle est tout d’abord le fruit d’un contexte.
C’est une réaction au paradigme psychologique
de la fin du XIXe siècle : on considère
à l’époque que tout problème de l’esprit
humain a sa source dans le corps, dans le
fonctionnement des nerfs, et on approfondit
donc l’étude des organes afin de corriger
les anomalies de l’âme. Mais — comme
on l’a vu dans la deuxième leçon de ce
module — les Français, eux, voient également
les choses dans l’autre sens : ils s’intéressent
aux causes psychiques des troubles (notamment
par le biais de l’hypnose). À presque 30
ans, Freud se rend (grâce à une bourse)
à Paris pour se former auprès de Jean-Martin
Charcot, qui l’impressionne par son éloquence
et son charisme. Il revient à Vienne avec
une nouvelle perspective sur l’esprit ainsi
qu’une nouvelle méthode, l’hypnose, qui
ne plaisent pas beaucoup à ses collègues.
Les deux autres influences décisives pour
la fondation de la psychanalyse sont celle
du médecin autrichien Josef Breuer (que j’ai
déjà mentionné), qui se servait déjà
d’une « cure par la parole » ; et celle
du médecin
de Berlin Wilhelm Fliess, qui fut son ami
le plus intime dans les années 1890, et dont
les idées sur la sexualité l’influenceront
fortement. Enfin, la fondation de la psychanalyse
est également le fruit d’influences philosophiques
inavouées (et plus discrètes), les plus
récentes étant celles de Schopenhauer et
Nietzsche (dont Freud était fan, et auquel
il se comparait en se présentant comme un
destructeur d’illusions).
Mais à quand dater la naissance de la psychanalyse
?
En 1892, alors qu’il a 36 ans, Freud a déjà
rassemblé les grandes lignes de la méthode
psychanalytique : l’observation minutieuse
; l’association libre (sans hypnose), qui
consiste à laisser le patient exprimer, sans
aucun contrôle, les pensées qui lui viennent
les unes après les autres ; et enfin l’interprétation.
Dans les dernières années du siècle, Freud
a l’ambition d’écrire l’ouvrage fondateur
d’une nouvelle psychologie scientifique
— mais il échoue.
Les actes fondateurs de la psychanalyse surviennent
entre les années 1900 et 1905. C’est la
publication de 3 livres phares — L’Interprétation
du rêve en 1900, la Psychopathologie de la
vie quotidienne en 1901, et les Trois essais
sur la théorie sexuelle en 1905 — qui diffuse
les idées de Freud et fait reconnaître la
psychanalyse dans l’opinion publique comme
une nouvelle thérapie psychologique. Deux
ingrédients ont été cruciaux dans ce succès
intellectuel : 1° les sujets des 3 livres
(le sens caché du rêve, celui des actes
manqués, et la sexualité) sont des sujets
qui fascinent les gens ; 2° Freud a un grand
talent de pédagogue : il écrit dans un style
très clair, avec beaucoup d’exemples.
Les actes publics de naissance de la psychanalyse
surviennent au tout début du XXe siècle,
mais la légende veut que le véritable point
de départ soit l’autoanalyse menée par
Freud à partir du milieu des années 1890
(ce qui n’est par définition vérifiable
par aucune preuve).
Enfin, la psychanalyse va encore évoluer
pendant plus de trois décennies. La sexualité
et le passé individuel (tout particulièrement
l’enfance) vont devenir des dimensions essentielles
de la doctrine. Freud va affiner sa carte
de l'esprit et la technique psychanalytique
; réviser ses théories sur les pulsions,
l'anxiété et la sexualité féminine ; envahir
l'histoire de l'art, l'anthropologie, la psychologie
de la religion et la critique culturelle.
Quels sont ses cas les plus célèbres ?
Freud reçoit beaucoup de patients parce qu’il
a besoin d’argent (il consulte 10 heures
par jour, disent les biographes). Ce sont
ces nombreuses consultations qui ont fourni
la base empirique à partir de laquelle il
a élaboré la doctrine psychanalytique.
Je vous résume brièvement les 5 cas classiques
de la psychanalyse.
1/ Le cas Anna O. est connu comme le tout
premier cas. Anna O. est une femme brillante
qui souffre (entre autres) d’hallucinations,
de troubles corporels et de troubles du langage.
Elle avait d’abord été traitée par Josef
Breuer — c’est même elle qui avait baptisé
sa méthode « la cure par la parole » — puis
Freud a pris le relais. Pour la guérir, ils
cherchent les événements de son passé qui
pourraient être à l’origine des troubles.
Dans les Études sur l'hystérie qu’ils
ont coécrites, ils affirment avoir fait disparaître
tous les symptômes les uns après les autres.
C’est toutefois un mensonge : l'état d'Anna
O. ne s'est pas amélioré ; elle a fait des
rechutes, au point de passer la suite de sa
vie en clinique psychiatrique. Breuer souhaitait
même qu'elle meure afin de mettre fin à
ses souffrances
2/ Le cas Dora est un cas d’hystérie. Dora
est une jeune fille de 17-18 ans envoyée
par son père parce qu’il souhaite qu’elle
accepte les avances du mari de la femme dont
le père est l’amant (oui, je n’invente
pas). Freud explique ses symptômes par un
événement du passé traumatisant (l’homme
auquel elle se refuse l’a embrassée quand
elle avait 13 ans), et par une masturbation
excessive. Dora, qui a l’esprit critique,
n’est pas convaincue, et interrompt le traitement
après 11 semaines. Il faudra attendre la
fin des Trente Glorieuses pour que des analystes
soient choqués du fait que Freud se soit
mis au service d'un père manipulateur.
3/ Le cas du « petit Hans » est le cas d’enfant
le plus célèbre. Hans, le fils du disciple
de Freud Max Graf, a une peur intense des
chevaux à partir de l’âge de 4 ans, au
point qu’il ne veut plus sortir de sa maison.
Son père pense immédiatement que c’est
parce qu’il a peur du grand pénis du cheval.
Hans raconte qu’il a vu un cheval chuter
juste en face de leur maison et qu’il a
aussi entendu un père dire à sa fille qu’un
cheval pourrait la mordre — mais Freud et
le père pensent que cela ne peut pas être
aussi simple. Ils préfèrent attaquer le
problème avec les grands concepts de la psychanalyse.
Freud revoit Hans à 19 ans, et c'est « un
magnifique jeune homme »... qui ne se souvient
plus de rien.
4/ Le cas de « l’homme aux rats » est
un cas de névrose obsessionnelle. Le patient,
un avocat dénommé Ernst Lanzer, est obsédé
par le souvenir d'une torture orientale (fixer
sur les fesses un pot dans lequel il y a des
rats), et il imagine que la femme qu'il aime
ainsi que son père subissent ce supplice.
Il a encore d’autres phobies. L’interprétation
de Freud est que l'avocat veut sodomiser et
son amie et son père (pour se venger de la
menace de castration), et qu’il en veut
à son père de lui avoir interdit de se masturber
quand il avait 6 ans. Bien que familier des
idées de Freud, le patient n’est pas convaincu.
Comme pour les autres cas, il est difficile
d’évaluer l’efficacité du traitement.
Freud affirme avoir guéri l’avocat, mais
il aurait avoué à certains de ses disciples
que non. Enfin, c’est impossible à vérifier,
car l’« homme aux rats » a été tué
au début de la Première Guerre mondiale.
5/ Le cas de « l’homme aux loups » est
le plus controversé. Le patient, Sergius
Pankejeff, est le fils d’un des hommes les
plus riches du sud de la Russie. Il a fait
deux analyses chez Freud (de 1910 à 1914
et en 1919-1920), et il détient divers records
: celui des années d’analyse (environ 60
ans), celui du nombre de cures analytiques
(une dizaine), et enfin celui des commentaires
sur son cas. Son surnom vient du cauchemar
par lequel Freud prétend avoir élucidé
le cas : entre l’âge de 3 et 5 ans, le
patient aurait rêvé qu’un groupe de 6
ou 7 loups blancs seraient rentrés par la
fenêtre de sa chambre, et qu’ils le regardaient.
Pour Freud, ce rêve signifie que l'enfant
aurait été témoin d'un coït parental dans
les deux premières années de sa vie. Freud
affirme avoir résolu le cas dès la première
cure, mais l’homme aux loups sera en réalité
traité pour ses problèmes psychologiques
(par d’autres psychanalystes, ou même à
l’asile) jusqu’à sa mort, à l’âge
de 92 ans.
Avec le recul historique, nous savons aujourd’hui
que ces cas classiques ne constituent probablement
pas des réussites thérapeutiques. Cependant,
il faut aussi reconnaître, étant donné
la nouveauté de la psychanalyse à l’époque,
qu’on envoyait à Freud les cas les plus
difficiles, ceux que tous les autres thérapeutes
avaient échoué à traiter.
Quelle est sa postérité ?
« Je ne suis rien d’autre qu’un conquistador
par tempérament. »
— Sigmund Freud, Lettre à Fliess de 1900
Freud a eu une influence exceptionnelle à
3 échelles.
En premier lieu, son nom est devenu synonyme
de psychanalyse. Il existe certes d’autres
doctrines psychanalytiques et d’autres grands
psychanalystes, mais l’aura de Freud écrase
toute la concurrence. Encore aujourd’hui,
les psychanalystes fondent leur pensée et
leur pratique sur l’œuvre de Freud, qui
a un peu pour eux l’importance qu’a la
Bible dans les religions chrétiennes. Ils
n’ont pas renoncé aux grands concepts freudiens
alors que les efforts de vérification (par
l’expérience et par le raisonnement) ont
conclu que ces concepts sont pour le moins
fragiles. Même Jacques Lacan, le seul psychanalyste
à avoir joui d’une autorité intellectuelle
comparable à celle de Freud — et encore
— même Lacan interprétait les idées de
Freud avec prudence, sans donner explicitement
l’impression que le fondateur de la psychanalyse
ait pu faire fausse route.
En second lieu, Freud a eu une grande influence
dans la sphère intellectuelle. Nombreux sont,
après la Première Guerre mondiale, les penseurs
qui se sont servis des idées de Freud pour
échafauder leurs propres théories. Sartre,
qui était fasciné par Freud, a par exemple
voulu fonder une psychanalyse existentialiste.
La grande influence du freudisme se manifestera
plus généralement par la domination, au
XXe siècle, de ce qu’on appelle la « philosophie
du soupçon », dont les trois piliers sont
la pensée de Marx (qui a soupçonné la société),
celle de Nietzsche (qui a soupçonné le christianisme),
et enfin celle de Freud (qui a soupçonné
la conscience individuelle). Notez que cela
fait de Freud un grand penseur, et même plus
précisément un philosophe — pas un grand
scientifique.
Cette grande influence intellectuelle se retrouve
naturellement dans la sphère académique.
Si vous avez étudié la philosophie en classe
de terminale en France, alors vous vous souvenez
peut-être que Freud est au programme (aux
côtés de Platon, Aristote, Kant, etc.).
Et cela continue à l’université. J’ai
moi-même suivi un séminaire sur Freud dans
le cadre de mon Master de philosophie politique
à la Sorbonne (autrement dit, on donne à
Freud la même importance qu’à des penseurs
comme Aristote ou Rousseau).
En troisième lieu, Freud a eu une grande
influence dans la culture occidentale. Ses
idées ont pénétré la sagesse populaire
dont l’homme ordinaire se sert dans sa vie
quotidienne. Par exemple, nous avons aujourd’hui
tendance à interpréter tout écart verbal
ou toute relation entre un parent et son enfant
sous le prisme de la doctrine psychanalytique
(je me souviens que ma mère m’avait expliqué
qu’un garçon préfère sa mère en raison
du complexe d’Œdipe). Le freudisme a plus
largement changé les mentalités. Stefan
Zweig estime qu’il a réduit le poids de
la morale sociale sur la psychologie individuelle.
« Par cette vision meilleure des lois psychiques
il a propagé dans le monde
une délicatesse et une indulgence plus grandes.
»
— Stefan Zweig, Sigmund Freud
Le freudisme est aussi une des forces à l’origine
de la révolution des mœurs des années 1960.
La sociologue américaine Sherry Turkle avance
dans La France freudienne que la psychanalyse
s’est massifiée parce qu’elle légitime
les conversations sur le sexe et parce qu’elle
constitue une justification rationnelle de
la libération sexuelle.
Quelles sont les idées essentielles de Freud
?
Je vais vous expliquer les quatre idées les
plus importantes de Freud : l’inconscient
; le refoulement ; le complexe d'Œdipe ; et
le malaise dans la civilisation.
Qu’est-ce que l’inconscient ?
L’inconscient se définit par opposition
à la conscience. Perçu comme un lieu caché
ou une force obscure à l’intérieur de
l’esprit humain, il désigne tout ce qui
échappe entièrement à la conscience, malgré
tous les efforts de la réflexion pour l’atteindre.
Par exemple, si l’homme aux loups a oublié
le coït parental auquel il a assisté dans
les premières années de sa vie, le souvenir
demeure dans son inconscient, selon Freud.
L’hypothèse de l’inconscient rend nécessaire
d’abandonner l’idée de l’unité du
sujet. L’esprit humain est partagé entre
deux pôles : la conscience et l’inconscient.
Freud voit dans ces deux pôles deux champs
spatiaux opposés et incompatibles, qui se
protègent l’un de l’autre.
« Le Moi n’est pas maître dans sa propre
maison. »
— Sigmund Freud, Introduction à la psychanalyse
Il existe diverses manifestations de l’inconscient.
Cela peut tout d’abord être le cas de troubles
physiques (on parle de « somatisation ») ou
psychiques, à l’image des symptômes d’Anna
O. L’inconscient profite également des
moments de faiblesse de la conscience pour
s’exprimer. C’est ce que Freud appelle
les « actes manqués » : les oublis de noms
propres, de mots de langues étrangères,
de noms communs et de suites de mots, de mots
liés à l’accomplissement d’un projet,
de projets mêmes, de connaissances ; les
faux souvenirs, les souvenirs-écrans (qui
masquent des souvenirs refoulés) ; les lapsus
; les erreurs de lecture et d’écriture
; les maladresses, les erreurs, et les accidents.
Enfin, les rêves constituent le moyen d’expression
par excellence de l’inconscient.
Qu’est-ce que le refoulement ?
Freud définit le refoulement comme une conséquence
naturelle de la division de l’esprit entre
la conscience et l’inconscient. C’est
le mécanisme par lequel des représentations
liées à certaines pulsions sont écartées
du champ de la conscience, repoussées ou
maintenues dans l’inconscient, parce que
leur satisfaction est incompatible avec d’autres
exigences matérielles, sociales ou morales.
Les pensées ou les souvenirs refoulés sont
en général de nature sexuelle. Par exemple,
le garçon refoule le désir sexuel qu’il
éprouve pour sa mère parce que la morale
sociale condamne ce désir.
Dans le détail, le refoulement d’une pulsion
survient uniquement dans le cas où le motif
de déplaisir est supérieur au motif de plaisir
concomitant. La faim, par exemple, est une
pulsion qui ne peut pas être refoulée — elle
doit forcément être satisfaite. En revanche,
le prétendu désir sexuel du garçon pour
sa mère, s’il s’exprime, apportera plus
de déplaisir (le déplaisir des sanctions
sociales) que de plaisir — c’est pourquoi
il est refoulé.
« La satisfaction de la pulsion soumise au
refoulement
ferait naître du plaisir à tel endroit,
du déplaisir à tel autre. »
— Sigmund Freud, Le refoulement
Enfin, le refoulement est également un processus
mobile. Il n’est pas un événement unique
au succès durable — il s’agit au contraire
d’un processus permanent à l’effectivité
précaire, conditionnée à un perpétuel
investissement d’énergie. Le refoulé exerce
une pression constante vers le conscient,
duquel il subit en même temps une pression
contraire. Seul le sommeil suspend le travail
de refoulement, de nouveau actif au réveil.
L’objectif du psychanalyste est faire remonter
le contenu inconscient à la conscience, ce
qui est censé supprimer les symptômes. Mais
cela n’est pas facile : la censure intérieure
du patient entrave souvent le travail analytique
par ce que Freud appelle la « résistance
».
Qu’est-ce que le complexe d'Œdipe ?
Le complexe d'Œdipe est, pour Freud, la grande
découverte de la psychanalyse : c’est le
désir de l’enfant pour le parent de l’autre
sexe, et son hostilité pour celui du même
sexe.
Ce concept est inspiré du mythe d’Œdipe,
issu de la tragédie Œdipe roi de Sophocle,
le grand dramaturge grec du Ve siècle avant
J.-C.. En voici un résumé : Œdipe est le
fils du roi de Thèbes, Laïos, et de Jocaste.
À sa naissance, les oracles prédisent qu’une
fois adulte, il tuera son père et épousera
sa mère. Il est donc abandonné, puis recueilli
par une famille, si bien que personne, pas
même lui, ne sait qui il est. Adulte, il
revient à Thèbes. Il rencontre un vieillard
(son père), le combat et le tue. Le trône
désormais vide et la main de sa mère lui
seront donnés parce qu’Œdipe aura su répondre
à la fameuse énigme du sphinx.
C’est donc sans le savoir — c’est-à-dire
inconsciemment — qu’Œdipe commet le parricide
et l’inceste. Cette situation qui se réalise
dans la légende serait présente à l’état
de désir dans toute âme d’enfant. Le mythe
serait révélateur de l’évolution sexuelle
du petit garçon, mais aussi de celle de la
petite fille (appelée « complexe d’Électre
»), où les rôles sont inversés.
Freud a avoué que l’idée lui avait été
inspirée par son propre désir pour sa mère,
qui était à la fois jeune et belle, tandis
que son père avait 20 ans de plus (c’était
son second mariage).
« Freud voulait vraiment tuer son père.
»
— Sándor Ferenczi (psychanalyste hongrois
qui a été le disciple préféré de Freud)
Qu’est-ce que le malaise de la civilisation
?
Cette idée est celle que je trouve la plus
intéressante. Freud écrit Malaise dans la
civilisation en un été, à 73 ans, après
la Première Guerre mondiale, qui invite à
réfléchir au penchant à l’autodestruction
de l’humanité.
Comme beaucoup de savants spécialistes, Freud
élargit sa perspective à la fin de sa vie.
Il applique donc ses idées à la civilisation
tout entière. Et pour ce faire, il procède
comme avec un patient individuel : il recherche
dans le passé, c’est-à-dire qu’il s’intéresse
aux formes primitives de la société humaine.
Il imagine que les premiers hommes vivaient
en petites hordes. Or, déjà à cette plus
petite échelle de la vie collective, l’homme
se rend compte que ses désirs sont bornés
par la résistance de ses semblables. Conclusion
de Freud : toute vie sociale, même au degré
le plus bas, exige une limitation.
Cette idée lui permet de répondre à la
question à laquelle Rousseau avait répondu
dans son Discours sur les sciences et les
arts : pourquoi le développement de la civilisation
ne rend-il par l’homme plus heureux ? Pourquoi
l’individu moderne éprouve-t-il un malaise,
c’est-à-dire un mécontentement chronique
? Eh bien, répond Freud, parce que l’enrichissement
par la culture ne lui a pas été donné gratuitement
: il le paie par une limitation inouïe de
la liberté de ses instincts. Autrement dit,
l’envers de tout gain de civilisation pour
l’espèce est une perte de bonheur pour
l’individu. La raison fondamentale est que
la fonction de la culture est de pousser l’individu
à faire passer l’intérêt collectif avant
son intérêt individuel.
Cependant, le malaise n’est pas une fatalité.
L’homme civilisé peut atteindre le bonheur
par ce que Freud appelle la sublimation : il
détourne l’énergie des pulsions dangereuses
pour la société (tout particulièrement
les pulsions sexuelles) vers d’autres buts
dont il attend une satisfaction esthétique,
intellectuelle ou sociale. Ainsi, plutôt
que de vivre dans la frustration, l’homme
peut dépenser l’énergie de ses désirs
dans l’art, la littérature, la politique,
etc.
« La sublimation est une des sources de la
production artistique. »
— Sigmund Freud, Trois essais sur la théorie
sexuelle
Quels sont les développements majeurs de
la psychanalyse ?
Je vais tout d’abord vous parler du développement
entrepris, indépendamment de Freud, par Jung,
le deuxième psychanalyste le plus influent
dans la culture occidentale. Je vous parlerai
ensuite de la psychanalyse lacanienne qui
a conquis la France dans les années 1960.
Enfin, je terminerai par vous présenter trois
autres psychanalystes majeurs qui méritent
une place dans votre culture générale.
Comment Jung s’écarte-t-il de la psychanalyse
de Freud ?
Carl Gustav Jung est un psychiatre suisse,
plus jeune que Freud de 20 ans. Intéressés
par les mêmes questions, ils s’écrivent
dans les années 1900. Au début, le jeune
Jung voue une admiration sans bornes à son
aîné ; réciproquement, Freud le tient en
estime pour plusieurs raisons : Jung a été
l'assistant de Bleuler, un expert mondialement
reconnu en matière de psychiatrie ; Jung
a réussi à assembler un groupe de freudiens
d'un bon niveau intellectuel ; enfin, Jung
n’est pas juif, ce qui permettra que la
psychanalyse ne passe pas pour une secte juive
dans l’atmosphère antisémite de l’époque.
Les deux hommes sont très proches — par
exemple, Jung se confie à Freud lorsqu’il
craint que sa relation avec une patiente ne
dégénère en scandale — et Freud confie
de plus en plus de responsabilités à Jung
dans le mouvement psychanalytique.
Seulement, Jung se rend compte de la fragilité
de certaines conceptions freudiennes fondamentales.
Il accuse son maître de donner une importance
disproportionnée à la sexualité (il rejoint
par là tous ceux qui reprochaient à Freud
son « pansexualisme », c’est-à-dire sa
propension à expliquer tout acte par une
motivation sexuelle).
« Mon travail pratique m’avait fait connaître
de nombreux cas de névroses
dans lesquels la sexualité ne jouait qu’un
rôle secondaire. »
— Carl Gustav Jung, Ma vie
Il doute également de la pertinence du complexe
d'Œdipe. À ses yeux, ce n’est pas le désir
d’inceste qui est universel, mais l’évitement
de l’inceste. Les mâles sont programmés
pour perpétuer l’espèce avec de jeunes
femmes fertiles et non pour s’accoupler
avec leur mère. Le conflit intellectuel dégénère,
comme c'est souvent le cas, en conflit affectif.
D’un côté, Freud reproche à Jung d'adapter
la théorie psychanalytique à la morale sociale
; de l’autre, Jung, qui avait donné à
Freud l’idée de l’analyse didactique
(que chaque psychanalyste se fasse psychanalyser
par un confrère), lui reproche de ne pas
s’y soumettre lui-même.
Ils rompent l’année du déclenchement de
la Première Guerre mondiale, en 1914.
Jung crée alors sa propre version de la psychanalyse,
la « psychologie analytique ». Son originalité
réside dans l’étude des relations entre
les dimensions individuelle et collective
de l’esprit humain (Jung prend par exemple
en compte l’influence des mythes et des
traditions dans le façonnage des mentalités).
On appelle cela la « psychologie des profondeurs
».
Voici les 3 idées majeures de Jung :
1. L’inconscient collectif — L'inconscient
est composé de deux couches : la première,
superficielle, est l'inconscient personnel
; la seconde, plus profonde et innée, est
formée de contenus que partagent tous les
individus sans exception, un fondement psychique
universel, suprapersonnel, présent en chacun
: l'inconscient collectif
2. Les archétypes — Les hommes ont tendance
à utiliser, à toutes les époques de
l'Histoire et en tout lieu, les mêmes modèles
élémentaires de comportement et de représentation,
inscrits dans la structure même du cerveau
: les archétypes. Ce sont en pratique des
images archaïques et universelles rencontrées
avec une récurrence remarquable dans les
rêves, les croyances religieuses, les mythes
et les contes.
3. La persona — Il existe dans l’esprit
humain une fonction d’adaptation à la société.
En effet, la personnalité de l'individu
s'adapte dans son rapport à ses semblables
pour prendre l’apparence d'un personnage
au rôle social prédéfini, une sorte
de « masque » (la persona) qui risque d'usurper
à la longue sa véritable identité.
J’ai développé ma présentation de Jung
parce qu’il est, après Freud, le psychanalyste
qui a eu le plus d’influence sur la culture
occidentale. Il doit en partie sa popularité
au fait qu’il s’est intéressé à des
phénomènes propres aux nouvelles spiritualités
qui ont émergé à la fin des Trente Glorieuses
en Occident : la connexion spirituelle entre
les êtres humains, les synchronicités, et
même les OVNIS.
Comment Lacan devient-il le nouveau Freud
?
Jacques Lacan est un psychiatre français
du XXe siècle. Surnommé « le Freud français
», il est la véritable star française de
la psychanalyse. Son influence est si grande
qu’à la fin des Trente Glorieuses, la psychanalyse
française est intégralement « lacanienne
», tant Lacan a formé de disciples. Comme
je vous l’ai dit au début de cette leçon,
il a rendu encore plus facile d’obtenir
le titre de psychanalyste en créant sa propre
société de psychanalyse.
L’histoire de la création de cette société
est révélatrice du personnage. Depuis les
années 1950, la Société Française de Psychanalyse
rappelle Lacan à l'ordre afin qu'il respecte
la règle des 45 minutes (lui vend des séances
très courtes). Il promet, il s’énerve
— mais il ne change rien. En 1963, la Société
Française de Psychanalyse lui retire son
titre de didacticien par la « Directive de
Stockholm ». Il réagit donc en créant sa
propre société et en libéralisant considérablement
les règles d’obtention du titre et d’exercice.
Il a, comme Freud, une grande influence. Chez
les intellectuels, il inspire par exemple
Althusser, Badiou, Derrida, Wahl, et même
des théologiens catholiques. Il est classé
parmi les inspirateurs de Mai 68 bien qu’il
ne soit ni révolutionnaire, ni même de gauche.
Que retenir de l’œuvre de Lacan ? Pour
faire simple, il développe la théorie psychanalytique
en se concentrant sur les effets du langage
sur l’esprit humain.
Il distingue 3 ordres dans le rapport de l’homme
au monde :
1. l’ordre du réel, soit l'objet en lui-même,
même si l’esprit humain ne peut pas atteindre
l’essence de l’objet ;
2. l’ordre symbolique, qui est le domaine
des images de langage associées à l'objet
;
3. l’ordre imaginaire, qui rassemble tous
les fantasmes du sujet à propos de l'objet.
Je ne développe pas davantage ma présentation
des idées de Lacan parce que je crains qu’il
ne soit un charlatan — en cela, il ne nous
permet pas de mieux comprendre le monde (c’est
plutôt même le contraire). En effet, son
propos est d’une obscurité inouïe (au
point que le philosophe Jean-François Revel,
par exemple, considère qu’il relève de
l'escroquerie verbale), et Lacan laissait
délibérément planer le doute sur le sens
de son propos pour fasciner ses auditeurs
(qui perdaient ensuite leur temps à essayer
de comprendre).
« Mes Écrits, je ne les ai pas écrits pour
qu'on les comprenne,
je les ai écrits pour qu'on les lise. »
— Jacques Lacan à propos de ses Écrits
Si Freud a défendu des idées contestables,
il a pour sa part toujours écrit avec le
souci de se faire comprendre. Il méprisait
ce qu’il appelait « l'idolâtrie des mots
».
Quels sont les autres psychanalystes importants
?
Voici 3 autres psychanalystes qui méritent
une place dans votre culture générale :
1. Alfred Adler est un médecin autrichien
de 15 ans plus jeune que Freud. Comme Jung,
il est d’abord un fidèle du fondateur de
la psychanalyse, avant de rompre à cause
de désaccords théoriques. Viré de l’association
de Freud, il crée alors sa propre école
de psychanalyse, la « psychologie individuelle
», ainsi que sa propre association (qu’il
appelle la « Société pour la libre recherche
psychanalytique »). Sur le plan des idées,
Adler, admirateur de Nietzsche, explique tout
par la volonté de puissance : chaque individu
éprouve, dès l’enfance, un sentiment d’infériorité,
et s’efforce dès lors de le surmonter en
recherchant la puissance.
2. Erich Fromm est un sociologue et psychanalyste
américain d'origine allemande du XXe siècle.
Il est un des représentants majeurs du freudo-marxisme
qui, comme le nom l’indique, consiste à
combiner le marxisme et le freudisme. Ce mélange
conduit Fromm à remettre en cause les idées
de Freud qui ne prennent pas en compte l’effet
de la culture sur le développement psychologique.
Dans sa perspective, la culture et les conditions
d’existence présentes ont le rôle respectivement
de la sexualité et du passé dans la perspective
de Freud. L’objectif qu’il donne à sa
théorie est de libérer l’homme de l’importance
qu’a prise la consommation dans son esprit.
3. Françoise Dolto est une pédiatre et psychanalyste
parisienne du XXe siècle. Elle représente
la concrétisation de l’ambition qu’a
eue Freud, à la fin de sa vie, de faire de
la psychanalyse une formation à la pédagogie.
De fait, la France est le pays où la psychanalyse
a le plus imprégné la pédagogie grâce
au succès de Françoise Dolto. Dans les années
1970, elle devient très populaire grâce
à une émission de radio où elle répond
« psychanalytiquement » à des lettres de
parents. Sur le fond, ses idées les plus
influentes reviennent à la nécessité de
libéraliser l’éducation : il ne faut pas
dévaloriser l’enfant comme un individu
de moindre valeur par rapport à un adulte
; il faut lui dire la vérité ; et Dolto
légitime la crise d’adolescence comme une
étape de vulnérabilité nécessaire en parlant
du « complexe du homard » (l’adolescent
est psychologiquement vulnérable parce qu’il
est en train de changer de carapace).
Quelles sont les limites de la psychanalyse
?
La psychanalyse s’est attiré beaucoup de
critiques dès ses origines : elles lui reprochent
d’usurper le statut de science ; d’être
motivée par l’enrichissement plutôt que
par la quête de la vérité ; et enfin, de
fonctionner comme une secte. Je vais examiner
ces trois reproches un par un et vous résumer
les débats qui les entourent.
La psychanalyse est-elle une science ?
La défiance des milieux scientifiques envers
la psychanalyse existe depuis son apparition
à la fin du XIXe siècle. Pour certains,
Freud était en réalité un philosophe, voire
un charlatan. Einstein, par exemple — avec
lequel Freud échange des lettres dans les
années 1930 — ne croit pas aux théories
psychanalytiques. Si son fondateur voyait
la psychanalyse comme une science naturelle,
les lacaniens, eux, rejetteront cette idée.
Le débat est relancé au début du XXIe siècle
en raison de la concurrence des thérapies
dites « cognitivo-comportementales » (TCC),
qui traitent les troubles par des exercices
pratiques centrés sur le comportement et
les processus mentaux (ce qui est une approche
bien plus concrète et pragmatique que celle
de la psychanalyse). Une partie des psychanalystes
essaient de se conformer aux critères de
la science moderne en se pliant aux exigences
de la « médecine par la preuve » (« evidence
based medecine » en anglais), les preuves
étant fournies par des études cliniques
systématiques.
Je vous résume le débat sur la scientificité
de la psychanalyse.
Voici les 3 principaux arguments POUR la scientificité
de la psychanalyse :
1. Elle est empirique et objective. En effet,
ses théories sont construites à partir de
faits issus de l’observation clinique. Lorsque
Freud présente ses idées, il précise qu’elles
lui ont été inspirées par un grand nombre
de cas. On peut toutefois déjà objecter
qu’il y a un biais d’échantillonnage
: les patients ne sont pas représentatifs
de l’humanité, car ce sont tous des personnes
à la fois troublées et financièrement aisées.
2. Il y a une relative unité autour des théories
de Freud. Ces théories constituent donc,
pour parler comme Thomas Kuhn, un « paradigme
», c’est-à-dire un cadre de travail accepté
par tous les acteurs de la discipline. Cet
argument est en réalité fragile, car, comme
on l’a vu, les grands concepts freudiens
ont été contestés dès le départ.
3. La théorie psychanalytique se corrige
en permanence. L’observation clinique ne
cesse de questionner et de réfuter la théorie,
ce qui garantit l’amélioration progressive
de l’adéquation entre la théorie et la
réalité. Il est vrai que l’édifice théorique
de Freud a évolué jusqu’à sa mort — cependant,
cette évolution est problématique dans la
mesure où Freud ajoute de nouvelles idées
bien plus qu’il n’en enlève (ce qui aboutit
à complexifier l’édifice théorique).
De grands concepts douteux comme le complexe
d'Œdipe n’ont pas été abandonnés.
Voici les 3 principaux arguments CONTRE la
scientificité de la psychanalyse :
1. Elle manque de rigueur. C’est déjà
le cas au niveau des concepts fondamentaux,
qui ne sont pas définis précisément. Jung
raconte par exemple qu’il avait demandé
à Freud une définition précise du concept
de « libido », et qu’il n’avait jamais
obtenu la réponse. Le manque de rigueur transparaît
encore au niveau de l’enregistrement des
faits observés (qui sont parfois confondus
avec des interprétations), et au niveau des
interprétations de l’analyste, qui sont
en partie aléatoires, et qui en cela relèvent
bien davantage de l’art que de la science,
comme le dit Stefan Zweig dans sa biographie
de Freud. Nombre de psychanalystes sont certes
d’impressionnants érudits, mais l’érudition
et la science sont deux choses différentes.
2. Elle se protège contre la réfutation.
Le philosophe Karl Popper, qui s'enthousiasmait
pour la psychanalyse dans les années 1910,
s’est ensuite rendu compte que la plus grande
force apparente de la psychanalyse, son irréfutabilité,
était en réalité sa plus grande faiblesse.
De son point de vue, le problème réside
précisément dans le concept d’inconscient,
qui permet de dire que les intentions véritables,
mais dissimulées, de l’individu sont toujours
conformes à la théorie.
« Ceux qui refusaient la théorie refusaient
de voir l’évidente vérité à cause de
refoulements non encore analysés et réclamant,
de façon criante, une thérapie. »
— Karl Popper, Conjectures et réfutations
3. Elle est fondée sur des mensonges. Je
vous ai déjà donné quelques exemples avec
les 5 cas classiques de la psychanalyse freudienne.
Pour l’historien néerlandais Han Israëls,
Freud était si confiant dans ses premières
théories qu’il s’était publiquement
vanté de succès thérapeutiques qu’il
n’avait en réalité pas encore obtenus.
Et quand les résultats n’ont pas été
au rendez-vous, il a été contraint de mentir…
J’ai une hypothèse personnelle plus précise
sur cette question : Freud ne pouvait pas
être humble et prudent comme un scientifique
parce qu’il consommait trop de cocaïne.
La psychanalyse est-elle un business ?
Les critiques de la psychanalyse lui reprochent
souvent sa dimension mercantile. Elle serait
un juteux commerce, ce que les bénéficiaires
essaient à la fois de dissimuler et de protéger.
Le prix des séances apparaît d’autant
plus élevé de nos jours que celui des thérapies
« cognitivo-comportementales » (TCC) est
inférieur.
« Ça s'arrête tout seul quand le malade
n'a plus d'argent. »
— Un psychanalyste à propos de la fin du
traitement
Il est vrai que l’argent était une dimension
importante du développement du mouvement
psychanalytique. Cela s’explique probablement
par l’histoire personnelle de Freud. Il
a longtemps été impécunieux. Pendant ses
études, il faisait très attention à ses
dépenses ; et il a repoussé son mariage
pendant plusieurs années par manque de moyens.
Jeune adulte, il a encore emprunté de l’argent
auprès de ses connaissances. Il paraît donc
naturel qu’il ait profité du succès de
ses idées pour se libérer des soucis financiers
qui lui ont tant pesé. Lorsqu’il peut enfin
fixer ses propres tarifs, il s’en réjouit.
Ils augmenteront avec sa notoriété, jusqu’à
atteindre, paraît-il, 450 euros de l’heure.
Enfin, Freud fera de la psychanalyse une entreprise
familiale, avec sa fille Anna comme héritière
légale des archives et de l’œuvre, et
son fils Enrst à la tête de la maison d’édition.
C’est Jacques Lacan qui représente la dérive
mercantile de la psychanalyse. La solution
qu’il a trouvée pour décupler son chiffre
d’affaires n’est pas d’augmenter les
tarifs, mais de réduire la durée de la séance
(c’est l’origine de son conflit avec la
Société Française de Psychanalyse). En
instituant la technique des « séances à
durée variable » — appliquée spécialement
dans les didactiques —, Lacan analyse « didactiquement
» plusieurs dizaines de postulants par jour.
Au fil des années, les séances deviennent
de plus en plus courtes, parfois minuscules.
Comme un monarque, Lacan interrompt ses « sujets
» selon son bon plaisir et les renvoie à
la séance suivante (parfois le même jour
quelques heures plus tard). Le psychanalyste
Gérard Haddad raconte que Lacan lui disait
parfois « À demain » avant même qu’il
ne commence à parler. La célébrité de
Lacan lui assure une clientèle pléthorique,
et de riches Parisiens dépensent des sommes
folles chez lui.
« J’ai réussi en somme ce que dans le
champ du commerce ordinaire, on voudrait pouvoir
réaliser aussi aisément : avec de l’offre
j’ai créé la demande. »
— Jacques Lacan en 1958
Freud et Lacan se sont certes enrichis grâce
à leur pratique, mais il serait malhonnête
de disqualifier la psychanalyse à partir
de leurs seuls exemples.
On peut relativiser la dimension mercantile
de la psychanalyse. En premier lieu, c’est
le marché qui détermine les tarifs de la
psychanalyse. Les psychanalystes les plus
prestigieux sont, comme les médecins les
plus prestigieux, les plus chers — mais
la grande majorité des psychanalystes proposent
des tarifs abordables pour la classe moyenne
(en cherchant sur internet, on trouve des
psychanalystes à moins de 50€/h, même
à Paris). En second lieu, certains grands
noms de la psychanalyse ont essayé de la
sortir des classes aisées. Par exemple, Alfred
Adler (dont je vous ai déjà parlé) analysait
surtout des patients des classes moyenne et
inférieure (et leurs préoccupations étaient
d’ailleurs bien différentes de celles des
patients de Freud : elles étaient davantage
liées à l'existence matérielle ou à la
progression dans la hiérarchie sociale, plutôt
qu’à l’amour).
La psychanalyse est-elle une secte ?
Le philosophe Ludwig Wittgenstein (qui vivait,
comme Freud, à Vienne) explique le succès
de la psychanalyse par le charme du sujet
et par le charme personnel de Freud.
Certains vont plus loin en comparant la psychanalyse
à une secte :
* Le charme personnel de Freud fascine en
effet ses disciples au point qu’il fait
penser au charisme d’un gourou. Ses connaissances
parlent notamment de la puissance de son regard,
qui donnait l’impression de pénétrer jusqu’à
l’âme de l’interlocuteur. Une partie
de ses patients s’attachent à lui — il
n’est pas rare que des patientes tombent
amoureuses de lui, ce qui lui inspirera le
concept du « transfert », qui signifie que
l’analysé transfère l'amour pour les parents
sur l'analyste.
* L’histoire de Freud, ses prétendus succès
thérapeutiques et ses théories constituent
des mythes fondateurs qui ne sont pas remis
en cause par les psychanalystes (au contraire,
ils les protègent contre les suspicions des
observateurs extérieurs).
* Enfin, Freud a organisé et soudé le mouvement
psychanalytique un peu comme un mouvement
religieux. Il en protégeait l’unité idéologique.
Il passait beaucoup de temps avec ses plus
proches disciples et leur disait que leur
groupe devait rester uni contre l’hostilité
du monde extérieur. Il récompensait les
plus fidèles en leur confiant des responsabilités,
et il excommuniait, comme on l’a vu, ceux
qui n’adhéraient plus à ses théories.
Ces arguments valent également pour la psychanalyse
lacanienne : Lacan exerçait un grand ascendant
psychologique sur ses partisans ; ceux-ci
perdaient tellement de temps à essayer de
comprendre son discours qu’ils ne pensaient
pas à le remettre en cause ; Lacan a créé
sa propre association de gens soudés autour
des mêmes croyances.
Après, on peut relativiser la dimension sectaire
de la psychanalyse. Pour commencer, Freud
n’était pas un manipulateur, mais un brillant
intellectuel et un écrivain doué. Sa domination
n’a pas pu empêcher la rupture avec ses
disciples les plus brillants (qui n’étaient
donc pas des suiveurs sans esprit critique)
ni la dispersion de la psychanalyse en diverses
écoles. Enfin, le fait qu’elle se revendique
comme une science et qu’elle adhère à
l’idéal de la science empêche qu’elle
sombre dans l’irrationalité d’une secte.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.